[موسيقى]
الروايه
يعني نقطه مهمه عن رفض كتابه برقيه الشكر
للرئيس لانه سيطلق سراحك او صراح صديقك
احد ابطال الروايه ايضا واعتقد انه هذا
حصل مع
ربما مع مئات والالف العديد من الفكره
الرفض هنا من اين نبعت تحديدا
يعني هي عمليه اذلال
انه تجدني 15 سنه وبعد 15 سنه تجبرني انا
اكتب لك برقيه
اشكرك فيها
اي حكت عليها من فتره قرات انا كنت مقالي
عن كتاب لباحث ايرانيه اسمها شريعه
الطلقاني
بتحكي فيها عن
خلينا نقول دوافع الموجوده لدى النظام
السوري هو عن ادب السجون السوري وعن
السجون السوريه
[موسيقى]
فهي بتعزي الامر اللي دافعين اساسيين
الدافع الاول هو تحطيم الانسان من الداخل
بحيث يفقد قدرته في المستقبل على اي فعل
معارض لهذا النظام
والدافع الثاني لدى النظام
لهذه الجرعه من التعذيب هو ان يعيش
الانسان ذلا يدفعه الى ان يكون موالي
للنظام
بمعنى صحيح انه يعني كان يحصل ذلك لدرجه
انه احيانا يجبر البعض على كتابه هذا
التعهد بالدم كتير ناس كتبه يعني يجبرون
على ذلك
[موسيقى]